I’m currently finishing up a round of deck
reviews that will be out hopefully sometime soon,
and it made me think about the different hurdles
a deck can face. Not necessarily the mechanical
weaknesses of a deck, but the fundamental
challenges that make a possibly promising
deck dead in the water. So here, I’m going to
go through the four basic fail states of a deck,
the things that go so wrong they can
make it totally unworkable. All four
of these focus around the idea of a deck’s
“plan”, so the natural starting point is:
#1 — Your deck has no plan
This is the first way a deck can fail, and it
simply means that the different elements of
the deck just don’t really come together
to form something that makes sense—it’s
just a collection of cards. Now, I should be
clear here—it is absolutely possible to make
a deck that feels cohesive and has a sense of
direction without specifically thinking of “a
plan”. Some commanders or mechanics or card
types just naturally lend themselves well to
a focused deck that can win games—if you have
a Jodah the Unifier deck it’s going to be able
to create massive boards of legendary creatures,
and if you have a landfall deck it’s going to be
able to generate a large resource advantage
while putting on some pressure. However,
there are other mechanics where dedicating a deck
to them won’t automatically create something that
makes sense. Let’s say you really like the
deathtouch mechanic and you want to build a
deck around it. There’s Fynn the Fangbearer, but
you want something that includes black as well,
so maybe you grab The Serpent Society or Aveline
de Grandpre. You add some deathtouch-supporting
cards like Hooded Blightfang, and then drop in a
whole bunch of your favorite deathtouch creatures.
Great! But, is this actually a cohesive deck?
It really depends on how we filled out the deck.
“Deathtouch creatures” doesn’t really gesture at a
particular gameplay timeline, lategame boardstate,
or plan for winning, so a deathtouch deck could
have all sorts of stuff in it. Maybe it’s a
lot of combat damage to a player effects since
people don’t want to block deathtouch creatures,
maybe it’s some counter amplifiers to pair
with Aveline’s combat damage effect or The
Serpent Society’s ward, maybe it’s some snake
synergies since we’ve got a lot of those,
and maybe it’s just piles upon piles of
deathtouch creatures we like. Depending on
what we filled our deck with and how dialed
into it we were, the deck might feel great,
but it could also feel like an uncoordinated
mass of nothing. This is where plan comes in—a
deck should really have an idea of roughly
what specific boardstate it would like to
create when and how that boardstate will lead to
victory. If it instead just has a moodboard of
the most aesthetic-looking threshold creatures,
it’s going to run into all sorts of problems.
So okay, let’s say you figured things out. You
know who you are and what you want to
be doing. But what if that want isn’t
turning into reality? This is where we
get to the second failure condition.
#2 — Your deck fails to execute its plan
This is where you know what your deck
wants to be doing, but it just doesn’t
seem to consistently be happening, at least
not on a reasonable timeline. To solve this,
I need to introduce a deckbuilding concept that
I like to call “widening your on-ramp”. Magic:
the Gathering is a game of chance, and you can
think of your gameplan as a big bucket that your
deck is randomly firing tennis balls at. Sometimes
you’ll hit, and your desired gameplan will happen
on your desired timeline, while other times that
won’t happen—such is life. What this bucket system
represents—randomness—is entirely unavoidable,
but your deckbuilding choices control the size
of the bucket. Missing land drops will make up
some percentage of that miss territory—a large
percentage if your deck is strongly enabled by a
commander that costs four or more mana—so adding
lands to a deck that’s low on them can increase
the size of the bucket. Another thing that
increases the size of the bucket is trying to keep
your deck’s payoffs lower-costed and more broadly
useful. High-cost amplifiers generally increase
your deck’s peak power level, but these typically
don’t help you jump into your gameplan, so each
one you add also slightly narrows your deck’s
on-ramp. All sorts of other cards also might
slightly narrow your deck’s on-ramp, and I’ve
linked a video I made a couple months ago that
goes more into that, but long story short it can
go a long way if you make sure that a relatively
wide portion of your cards are helpful early.
The other thing that can widen your on-ramp is
card draw. If your deck isn’t seeming to work,
my first suggestion will always be to add
more draw and filtering. A lot of times
this will simply solve the problem, because a
ton of EDH decks aren’t running enough draw,
but that’s not the only benefit. Adding card draw
helps even if that’s not the main problem with a
deck because it helps to pick out what cards
are working and what cards aren’t. It’s easy
for a card that doesn’t work well to stay in your
deck if you only see it once every four games,
but bump that number up to one in three or one
in two and suddenly you’re coming face to face
with its issues a lot more often. The same goes
for cards that feel really good in your deck—if
you’ve got something that’s a surprise powerhouse,
drawing it in more games can help that become
clear, and you can modulate your deck to play into
its strengths accordingly. As a final note here,
sometimes the decks you play against might just
be faster than your desired plan can reasonably
be. You can optimize as much as you like, but
some ideas just aren’t suited for a particular
caliber of gameplan due to a limited pool of cards
or some inherent weaknesses. I might make a video
about those at some point, but for now I’m going
to move past them and assume you’ve succeeded in
assembling a deck that has a plan and is able
to execute it. What could go wrong from there?
#3 — Your plan sucks for other people
Commander is a social format. You’re
playing a game with three other people,
and you’re generally there to have a fun
time. So, what happens if you pull up with
your beautiful new creation and it just bums the
table right out? I wish this was an area where
I could just tell you what’s a-okay and what’s
off limits, but really it’s kind of complicated,
and there are two main variables at play here.
Variable one is who you’re playing with. Some
playgroups are going to be a lot more accepting of
spicy decks than others, and generally people who
have played the game longer will be on the more
accepting side. It might strike some people as
weird that a large group of players are okay with
lockout control and land destruction and the like,
but it makes more sense when we think about it in
terms of type 1 vs type 2 fun. Type 1 fun is doing
stuff that feels good in the moment, whereas type
2 fun is about doing stuff that kinda sucks in the
moment but is rewarding later. Playing a fiddly
midrange pile is type 1 fun, whereas defeating
an especially nasty opposing deck or navigating
a perilous situation falls more in the realm of
type 2 fun. This might sound like I’m grouping
people into type 2 players and type 1 players,
and there will be people who lean toward one or
the other, but ultimately almost all players are
going to enjoy a mixture of these two things, in
varying amounts. You’ll find the dino-playing-est
of Timmies getting jazzed at the sight of
some degenerate Zur the Enchanter nonsense,
and on the other hand you’ll get an old-school
player who doesn’t particularly want to play
against your Kefka deck today. And that’s the
important thing here—whether or not your opponents
want to play against a deck isn’t necessarily
an all-or-nothing question. They might be fine
playing against a spicy deck every once in a
while, but making a deck that’s more irritating
to play against might mean less times when your
opponents want to play against it, and if your
goal is to make an everyday default sort of deck
then that could easily constitute a failure.
The second variable here is your own willingness
to subject your opponents to things. If you know
that you’re somebody who will struggle to
enjoy playing your deck if your opponents
react negatively to things you do, you’ll want to
avoid some of the grittier tools out there. On the
other hand, if you don’t care one bit about your
opponents having fun, you’ll have a much wider
range of stuff you can do. Whether or not that’s
a good thing is another question, but it is a
true statement. Personally, I’m somewhere in the
middle—I like it when my opponents are having fun,
but I also tend to play decks that present a
very specific type of problem to my opponents,
and that isn’t always well-received in the
moment. Getting challenged is challenging.
Sometimes we end up driving through the outskirts
of frown-town, but I at least try not to stick
people in that same sort of difficult
situation for too long. It’s a balance,
but it’s what I need to do to play the decks
I like to play in social format. So okay,
let’s say your deck has a plan, it’s able to
accomplish that plan, and you can make peace
with whatever the opposing reaction to that
plan is. What else could possibly go wrong?
#4 — Your plan sucks for you
Sometimes, a deck just doesn’t live up to
our hopes for it. You imagine a particular
play pattern, a particular sequence of actions,
or a particular gamestate, but upon attaining
that you realize that it just isn’t that
fun for you. This is a very common issue,
and to me it’s just a part of figuring out what
it is that you enjoy within the commander format.
Some people enjoy finding the weirdest combos
out there, while others do not. Some people like
playing an extremely complicated pile of nonsense
where there’s always another possible line,
and to other people that sounds like hell. Some
people like making a massive board full of beasts,
and other people fall asleep playing that
sort of deck. You can take guesses as to
what you will or won’t like, but you won’t
know for sure until you’ve tried it out. And,
like the last failure condition, this one
isn’t necessarily all-or-nothing. You might
put together a deck that you really like
playing sometimes, but that simply can’t
be your bread and butter. That’s a failure if you
were looking to build a deck you play with a lot,
but it might not be so bad if you’re just looking
for variety. It’s also not a crime to get tired
of a deck eventually. If you build a deck that
executes a very cool, very specific gameplan, you
might get a kick out of playing it that first half
a dozen times, but it might lose its luster after
that. If you poured a ton of money into buying
it in paper and blinging it out, that’s gonna
sting a bit. However, a deck like that eventually
falling by the wayside doesn’t take away from it
being fun to play in those first handful of games,
doesn’t negate your past enjoyment. The key here
is expectations—if you’re building a deck, try
to have an idea of how often you expect to play
it and how long you expect it to stay fresh.
No deck is a failure if you have yourself in
the right mindset for it, and that mindset
is something you can build with experience.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt for
supporting the channel. Archidekt’s deck folder
system lets me comfortably group my “sometimes”
decks separately from my “always” decks, which
feels correct to me for some reason. Well, I guess
I have my Malfegor deck in the main deck folder,
but what can you say, a guy’s got his favorites.
A link to my decks is in the description. I’d also
like to thank Dragonshield for their support of
the channel and for keeping my decks secure. I’d
love to resleeve my Radha deck at some point but
I made a pact that I’d wait until a sleeve broke,
and so far those peach dual mattes are surviving
the thousands of shuffles I put them through just
fine. You can grab yourself your own set of dual
mattes at the affiliate link in the description,
and you can use code “salubrious” for 5% off.
Doing so supports the channel and lets me keep
doing what I do. Also supporting the channel
are my lovely patrons and youtube members,
some of whom are on screen now. If you want
to join this esteemed group of individuals,
you can join as a YouTube member or follow the
link to my patreon, also in the description.